[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE ALMERARIS: So I'm here
to talk to you guys today
about launching successful
VR and AR games with Google.
Before we do that, I just
want to kind of set the stage
and say how important VR
and AR are to our mission
here at Google.
We see them as kind
of the striking bound
of being the fourth
generation of computing.
So again, if you think
about that supercomputer
back at IBM's headquarters years
ago to when Dell really made
the PC kind of
approachable to the point
that now we all have a
supercomputer in our pockets,
we see VR and AR as leading
to that next-gen mixed reality
world of computing
that we're hoping to be
in in the next five years.
So with us, how have
we kind of started
to kind of hit the scale on that
particular kind of achievement?
It's through Daydream and Tango.
So we launched Daydream
on November 10th of 2016
at a $79 price point.
And Daydream itself
wasn't just a headset,
it was actually a
standard of phones.
And I'll get into
that in a minute.
And at the same
time, we actually
launched our AR
device, which is Tango,
which is a software
stack built directly
into the hardware of phones.
And that launched with
the Lenovo Phab 2 Pro.
So we're really, really excited.
And you'll continue to see
these two platforms evolve
over the next two years.
So when I start to
talk about Daydream,
it's really important that
we separate the headset
from the actual
standard of phones.
So Daydream Ready
is what we have
built into the hardware, which
is really about low persistence
displays.
It's about low latency,
high-quality sensors,
and it's about higher
performing SOCs.
To achieve that,
we've built directly
into Android N in order to give
us sustained performance, head
tracking, and system
UI, which we're
really, really excited about.
As part of that, we actually
just launched two new games
on Daydream, along with all
the other games and apps
that we currently
have since November.
When we think about
gaming with Daydream,
we really think about kind
of three major categories
for gaming.
The first, we think about
fictional teleportation
narratives, which is
really about breaking
that barrier of why I
would put a headset on,
and why I would want to immerse
myself and isolate myself
from the community around.
The second kind of type
of gaming that we really
think about is
connected experiences
because what we don't want to do
is isolate ourselves too much.
So we really want
to think about how
we collaborate in the same
virtual space together.
And the third kind
of way is thinking
about adrenaline
rushes, things that
are going to get my heart
pumping, whether it's racing
with EA's "Need for Speed"
or going through kind
of a haunted house maze with
"Layers of Fear" by Aspire.
So we're really, really
excited to kind of see
what you guys can come up
with, and how we can get that
into our platform.
When it comes to Tango,
it's really important
that we think about
software that brings
a human scale to the world.
It's still a phone.
It's still looking
through a magic window.
But it's taking advantage
of motion tracking, so full
six degrees of freedom.
It's taking advantage of depth
perception, which is really
about scale and geometry,
and getting as close
to an object as you need to be,
or as far back from an object,
and showing you real-world
what that object looks like.
And when you combine
these two things together,
you get what's called area
learning, which we're really
excited about.
So being able to drop
objects into this room,
for example, in augmented
reality, leaving the room,
leaving the building,
even leaving the city,
and coming back and
finding those objects
exactly where you left them,
which we're really, really
excited about.
When we think about
Tango, we're really
thinking about
mobile games that can
be enhanced with this
augmented reality today.
We're really thinking about
tabletop gaming, which, again,
if we're all playing
in a world around us,
and bringing those characters
to life right in front of us.
Or we're thinking about the
living playground-- being
able to bring virtual
pets into our space,
or bringing this room to life.
And so we're really
excited, again,
to see what you guys
can come up with.
And we're demoing some
of those cool new games
at our booth starting
on Wednesday.
So as you start to think
about, OK, these are great.
These platforms
seem really cool.
But how do I actually
get discovered?
Well, we've got
discoverability across both.
The first is our
Daydream VR Play
Store, which when you
go into the headset
you go directly into.
Daydream VR Play Store has full
IIP built directly into it.
And every user of
Daydream is required
to have a form of
payment on file.
So we're really, really excited
about driving monetization
for our developers.
On the Tango side, we continue
to evolve how collections
work on the 2D Play
Store to, again,
allow for discoverability
for our developers.
You can self-publish
via Play dev
console today for
either platform.
We know we heard our
developers loud and clear.
We did launch with a more
curated platform for Daydream.
And that was really
to put our processes
in place and kind of set the
bar of what quality means in VR.
But we absolutely
encourage everyone today
to go ahead and self-publish.
And we want to take advantage of
all that great organic content
that you guys were
already working on,
and bring it to the
forefront for our users.
Directions and how to do it
are located on our website.
But we really recommend,
for monetization, really
thinking about a try
before you buy model.
We know users really want
to understand duration
of what they're purchasing.
They want to understand
the environment
of where they're going to be.
And we really-- and
they really want
to understand the quality
of what you're delivering.
So for us, as we've
kind of learned
over the last
three, four months,
we really push
developers to think about
what does this try before
you buy model look like.
So, thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]